[Music]
these one-of-a-kind instruments are the
creation of david clavins
he's the mastermind behind some truly
unconventional pianos like this vertical
concert grand the tallest piano in the
world
we met david in a small town in hungary
when we made a short film about him
today he invites us to his workshop
where we can sit back and enjoy the
sound of each one of his unique pianos
okay come with me
this is the concert on the courthouse
and the colder comes from the fact that
it only has one string per node
it's like 2 meters tall and 2 meters 20
wide
[Music]
[Music]
this is one of my pianos the
unaccordable
the character is generally softer
each note in itself is always clear it
cannot be out of tune
[Music]
this is my biggest piano the vertical
concert grand of four meters 70.
the country piano has double strings
from the first bass note which no other
piano has makes it the fullest sounding
piano on the planet
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my main motivation to create the pianos
that we built today was that i had an
imagination of sound that didn't exist
as i found out in the course of my life
working with pianists they are also not
satisfied with traditional pianos
essentially i love to provide
people tools to create new and beautiful
music the world needs different sounds
better sounds more sounds in the piano
field
[Music]
you